Mama June says I do once again yes oh
yes oh yes oh yes the reality star
typing out with Justin Stroud Saturday
in an Oceanfront ceremony in Florida
nearly one year after their Courthouse
marriage in Georgia sharing that part of
my life that I've not shared with the
world the intimate wedding proved to be
a reunion for June spam for daughters
Honey Boo Boo pumpkin chubs and
chickadee were all in attendance with
June revealing it was the first time
they'd been together since 2014. just
like she knows what love is and that
this is true but everybody like and she
tells me that with everybody and it's
it's different with this one it's
different with Justin and I'm not saying
Justin's a bad guy by any means but I
also don't know him that well June's
strained relationship with Honey Boo Boo
and pumpkin played out publicly over the
last few years when she began facing
addiction and legal struggles okay
there's just a lot of stuff that went on
in our life so as the sisters told ET
last year their mom eloping came as a
big surprise I was more in shock because
my mama always said that she would never
get married she would never go off and
just get married with somebody she was
scared of marriage like to say the least
and now she went off and just got
married with this dude she hadn't even
known a whole year yet I genuinely don't
know him I don't know him enough to be
like okay he's no good
um none of that I've only known him by
his action and so far his actions
haven't really shown
okay I want to be a part Justin has
taught me not to become a runner and
feel the emotions then it feels good to
kind of be grounded for once in my life
but for June she explains how meeting
Justin changed her life the amazing
person that I met an amazing person a
little almost a year ago now we were
just friends they came into my life when
I was his friends he had no idea what
was going on in my life and small little
text messages of hey how you doing just
want to say hey have an amazing day I
was going through some hell learning who
I was learning who I was for the first
time you know who were coming in out of
my life and this person was just like
this is my person and people were just
like going like this
and it was showing me like if you go
back to if you think about going back
into that addiction lifestyle this is
where you're going to be at and then
there was people that would show me hey
you can be treated like a queen and you
know stuff like that but then that one
person was just I mean sitting up here
to the right to the left of me but it's
just you know
this person was right here the whole
time and I don't know and I started
really liking him and opened up the
chapter of our story September of last
year and
you know eight almost eight months ago
you know it's been a whirlwind fans can
catch June and Justin exchange vows on
the upcoming season of we TV's Mama June
family crisis
[Music]